dc has a history stretching back almost
a century
so naturally they've got a whole heap of
stories to tell from its legendary
library of elseworlds comics to its most
celebrated canonical tales
the choices are almost endless these are
the standalone dc movies we want to see
happen
catwoman has worn many hats in the dc
universe she's been a jewel thief driven
by
nothing but her own desire for decadence
she's been batman's lover
occasionally his fiancee and in a few
realities even his wife
she's done this green straight up
[Music]
catwoman has also been a member of
various villainous team-ups for as long
as her fiercely independent nature
allows that is
occasionally she's even been a hero
usually on her own terms and using some
pretty iffy tactics but a hero
nonetheless
her 2001 solo series exemplified this
and could well form the basis of an
incredible cinematic outing
in this story selena returns to the
slums of gotham's east end where she
once worked as a sex worker
a mentor to the other women and
eventually a burglar too
upon learning of a serial killer preying
upon the unprotected women of the
neighborhood
she decides to hunt down the culprit
herself and in so doing
learns to fight for the downtrodden the
city elite prefer to ignore
it's a brooding masterpiece of a series
and one that could easily make the jump
to the silver screen as a smoldering
neo-noir
tale of gotham streets darwin cook's
stylish mid-century take on selena and
her world provides
timeless aesthetic that wouldn't just
impress but
look unlike any other superhero story
committed to film
all in all catwoman would be more than
just an experiment
it would prove to be a dazzling new
vision of the superhero genre's
capabilities
from the 2003 animated teen titans
series to the deliriously delightful
teen titans go
it seems like audiences can't get enough
of robin and his motley crew of
sidekicks
and although most of these incarnations
draw inspiration chiefly from the 1980s
new
teen titans series there is enough life
in the idea of
adolescent adventuring to dig deeper
into the team's past
specifically to its original lineup
introduced in 1966
this team features robin kid flash
aqualad
speedy and wonder girl while the
original run has a timely charm of its
own
amy wolfram and carl herschel's teen
titans year one
depicts a modern vision of the team that
practically begs to be adapted to film
chafing beneath the demands of the
adults in their lives the merry band of
junior heroes strike out on their own
unsurprisingly they're not entirely
prepared to confront the villainy they
soon encounter
but the fledgling group doesn't dissolve
at this first flush of conflict
they rally fight back and eventually
form the team that would go on to make
such a mark on the dc
universe teen titans year one wouldn't
just be a lighthearted cave in cal romp
either but a genuine ode to the trials
of teen years
think of john hughes flick only with
magical lassos and the ability to talk
to fish
what could possibly go wrong barbara
gordon has been stylish from the very
beginning
take that ruffled motorcycle she wrote
in 1966 as batman for example
or her early pioneering of the library's
chic look
and the wide and fabulous array of
costumes in her closet
this attention to aesthetics informed
one of the most recent iterations of the
girl in the pointy-eared cow
the batgirl of burnside whose
cutting-edge adventures were chronicled
in her 2015 solo series
in this ode to life's early 20s barbara
moves to burnside
gotham's hippest neighborhood pulls on a
new costume and takes on a panoply of
punchy new adversaries
babstar's neon line vision of a gotham
is one
terrorized by influencers gone insane
mob connected cosplayers
and rogue viruses born from the bowels
of social media
and this would all fit right in
alongside some of the more daring visual
approaches filmmakers have taken to
gotham over the years
barbara's world throws itself into the
fantasy of superheroes
utterly uninterested in toning down what
makes these stories unique
there's no body armor or drab kevlar in
this batgirl's neck of the woods
instead you'll find doc martens
bedazzled utility belts
and bad guys who look more like takashi
murakami sculptures than military
operatives
a movie sprung from this vision wouldn't
just delight but
outright dazzle establishing batgirl as
her own hero with her own challenges
mission and neighborhood once upon a
time a boy named clark kent grew up in
rural kansas
think you know where this is going well
this clark kent wasn't raised in the
superpower rich environs of the dc
universe he lived in our world where
being named after superman was a
conscious
joke on the part of his parents young
clark bore the name abele but
inwardly resigned himself to a life of
ribbing and superman branded birthday
gifts
then one day he started to float a
metafictional tale of heroism
superman's secret identity examines just
what superheroes mean in our pop
culture-laden world
in many ways a movie adaptation of the
stirring story would serve as a
sort of lighthearted rejoinder to joker
an alternate origin story
in which clark not only embraces his
literal powers
but also assumes his figurative
responsibilities
knowing what it really means to make
superman real superman's secret identity
is a joyous invocation of the superhero
in everyone
a celebration of the spirit that led
jerry siegel and joe shuster to come up
with the big
blue boy scout in the first place this
is a superman that wouldn't just take up
the screen with his feats of goodwill
he filled the audience's hearts as well
the first suicide squad movie had an
undeniable cultural impact but its
critical reception was a little lacking
to say the least
harley quinn nice to meet you love your
perfume what is that the scent of death
and while there was much to loathe about
suicide squad it did prove one thing
the idea of a super team with muddled
morals is a potent one indeed
consider then a movie centered around
another team of dc characters who don't
always play by
rigid rules of good and evil the
outsiders the outsiders are a collection
of misfits oddballs and heroes who have
had more than a few
falls from grace yet they strive to do
good in spite of this
and often succeed thanks to their unique
gifts well-known characters like
nightwing
starfire and arsenal could anchor
audiences to stories they've already
experienced
allowing the film to introduce more
obscure heroes like looker
a bank teller turned do good or vampire
or indigo
a broken android from the far future who
is designed for villainy
the space to take creative liberties is
ample too some outsiders teams have
decades of visuals
lineups and plots to play with from
straightforward heroics to insidious
blackmail schemes
the outsiders could be interpreted as a
strike team off the books enforcers
a ragtag band of wannabes or practically
anything else
all it would take is the right bunch of
filmmakers to make this story really
soon wonder woman's first cinematic solo
outing was a roaring success
and there's likely room for more than
one interpretation of her astonishing
adventures
after all batman and superman have had
more than their share of screen time
according
to a vast array of directors writers and
actors so why not wonder woman too
wonder woman amazonia a 1997 elseworlds
story is particularly ripe for
adaptation
set in a turn of the century london
where jack the ripper has murdered his
way into becoming the king
the story finds diana battling an
entrenched patriarchy on the victorian
stage and the halls of power alive
its strong visuals would make a unique
splash on the screen
for example this wonder woman sports a
gibson girl hairstyle as she protects
the crowded streets of whitechapel
in many ways this wonder woman story
would have more in common with sweeney
todd than justice league
but that would be the movie's greatest
strength much as wonder woman succeeded
in placing its heroin in the maelstrom
of world war one
so too could this film highlight its
heroine's unique strength by rooting it
in a particularly dire chapter of
english history
it may seem impossible but when wonder
woman eventually triumphs against the
forces of violent systemic bigotry her
victory would be all the sweeter
for mr miracle juggling an
interdimensional war and a newborn son
is all part of the job
tom king and mitch garrett's meditative
take on the new gods character
juxtaposed his fantastic origins against
the mundanities of life on earth but
this wasn't simply an exercise in
contrast
king and garretts used the superheroic
whimsy of the dc universe to find feats
of titanic heroism in the
everyday and bring out the ordinary in
an interstellar clash of good and evil
picture it literal gods crowded around a
condo's coffee table
cooing over a baby who doesn't know the
meaning of the anti-life equation
or legendary villainous granny goddess
offering her prodigal children jello on
the battlefield
mitch garrett's lurid colors would
translate seamlessly to the celluloid
fever dream mr miracle could become
given the right creative team much like
superman's secret identity a mr miracle
movie could probe the boundary between
our world and the fictional ones we
create all driven by the high octane
power of jack kirby's legendary fourth
world stories
and of course it would be led by a
single all-encompassing question
can mr miracle the iconic escape artist
really escape his own mortality
the questions journey has been a strange
one indeed originally created for
charlton comics in 1967
he joined the dc universe alongside the
rest of the charlton heroes in the 1980s
though he is very much a hero his
approach to doing good is
often notably murky for example while he
doesn't kill he often considers it
and is usually far less bound by a fear
of crossing the line than some other dc
heroes
in this sense the question's mask
doesn't just obscure his identity but
his very humanity
a vibe he very intentionally goes for
there is a real edge to the question
a line he dances across frequently in
his desire to root out venality and
corruption wherever it hides
basically he's a good guy but not too
good unexpectedly
justice league unlimited proved that he
works as well as part of a group too
especially when paired in an unlikely
romance with a cunning huntress
all in all the question is the voice of
society's conscious that no one wants to
hear
the fringe thinker whose constant whole
poking and theorizing
is usually vindicated in the end he's
not your average superhero that's for
sure
superman is of course the original
superhero
his arrival sparked an entire genre
cemented in art form
and ultimately changed the course of
history his story's number in the
thousands his fans in the millions
he is an outright icon one whose appeal
has never really dimmed despite his
constant presence in western pop culture
i'm here to fight for truth and justice
in the american way but superman is also
a singular character with a unique
backstory
set of abilities and personality so what
better way to take a fresh approach to
the man in the cape than to go back to
the beginning and explore him in one of
his earliest roles
as a late 1930s urban crusader many of
his earliest comics saw superman
tackling social ills from corruption to
domestic violence
rooting his goodness in everyday life so
why not tell a superman story in that
era
imagine superman as a boy molded by the
depression as it unfolded in rural
kansas
taking on the undeserved populace of the
shining city he's moved to
imagine the power of a portrayal that
strips the character down to its
earliest essence
and in so doing finds him all the more
potent superman is an
alien a savior and a force for good and
sometimes
the best way to express that is by
showing him helping people on the ground
and portraying him as a guy in a cape
who just wants to make the world a
fairer place
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one